vous avez aimé turbo chef
voilà je n'ai pourtant parti sur garde
des sceaux
vous avez aimé on n'demande qu'à en rire
en terrain connu
et puis alors c'est quoi le nouveau
délire là avec les clopes électronique à
bientôt au pouvoir télécharger son
cancer sur internet
on imagine que vous allez adorer
n'oubliez pas d'épouser le juste un
terreau fort de la fortune faible pour
un champion factor et ses princes en or
lanta bonjour et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau npe jssp cfp ol
nous sommes aujourd'hui encore avec
romuald pour ça c'est en 51ème tentative
romuald et on est bientôt prêt ça va
commencer est ce que vous êtes confiant
ouais ça va être parfait 3 2 1
m
il est marrant
les ravers
le compte est bon
de quoi user jusqu'à 13 repas 16 208 ch
/ 4 52 52 x 7 pro 64 n'ont pas bonjour
mon petit romual temps mais je me fais
plaisir de vous voir
il m'entraîne au bout
à
allez la démo minuit au top je suis une
figure emblématique de la révolution
française est le bagne rabot à la une
est super bon moment corinne on a les
mêmes goûts musicaux c'est fou que m
j'adore ta personnalité mais choisir
seniors et d'user de tous les expédients
je suis je suis je suis robespierre
énoncées dans ton merci d'avoir
participé
romuald nous on se retrouve demain pour
un nouveau n'oubliez pas d'épouser le
juste interport de la fortune faible
pour un champion cette forme
mesdames et messieurs les jurés dans
notre société défigurée par
l'omniprésence de la culture
télévisuelle l'acte de mon client ne
vous paraît-il pas excusable irez vous
le fait que nos coutumes nos moeurs nos
vies sont parasités par la télévision
n'ont pas convaincu pour moi ça va en
prison on peut en y souscrivant être
prévenu de toutes les nouvelles web on à
bonnes toiles et tous les vendredis 18
heures il ya aussi les vidéos du lab en
exclusivité sur le site internet